Now it's worth putting out that this magical program, Texture Packer, provides a
nice little output option that you can see right here, called trim. What this
option will do, is that for each image, it'll find out the true boundaries for
it. So let's say an artist gives you a texture but only puts pixels in the
center part of it. The needed pixels of this image only occupy a sub-portion of
the physical space that's been provided. As such we get a lot of wasted pixels.
Texture packer provides this trim option that will go through and remove
unneeded and unused pixels, mostly transparent, from all of the sprites that are
given to an atlas. The results are actually pretty significant. You can see that
the size of the atlas that contains the blank unused pixels is significantly
larger than the one that trims properly. Now it's worth pointing out however,
that when you use this option the format of the data in your output JSON, from
Texture Packer is going to change a little bit. So previously the frame
parameters width and height values matched the same as the sort size. So if your
input image was 128 by 128, the size in your texture atlas was going to be 128,
128. And of course the trimmed value is false. Once you start with trimmed equal
to true, you'll notice that the frame width and height represents the true
boundaries of the used pixels in the input texture. It no longer matches the
size of the input texture exactly.